I'll make you a deal I'll forgive the
session fees if you'll be the newest
member of the Grand Ole Opry I told the
operator making a big mistake whatever
here we are I don't seem interested in
my opinion so yeah let's do this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back certified country
I'm so excited we are here at the Grand
Ole Opry in Nashville with Chris Young
on such an exciting night yeah I would
say probably one of the most exciting
nights of my life
[Music]
your debut was more than ten years ago
now yes how well do you remember that
moment I I actually told somebody this
earlier what I remember most was that
they put me a room but they didn't tell
me how I was supposed to do I mean
obviously you're supposed to go out and
perform on the stage but I didn't know
like what side of the stage I went on I
didn't know when I was supposed to leave
the room like I I was there by myself
you know I was really really lost and
really nervous and excited and it was
just a really really cool night though
you had a pretty incredible reaction to
being invited you picked skill up and
everybody's sick yeah this is a small
guy and I'm like well I'm 6 for 250 I
just picked him up that wasn't thinking
about it at the time and then it was
really funny because I was like how
great this photo is gonna be everywhere
and it is what is Brad Paisley in store
for tonight
you know everybody's asked me they're
like well so what what's gonna happen
tonight I I really don't know yeah I've
never actually been to anyone else's
induction so I haven't even gotten to
see it secondhand and it's mine so this
first time I've been inducted so I don't
I don't know but I love Brad I'm sure he
will make fun of me
[Music]
tell me about your relationship with
Chris well he is one of the sweetest
greatest people that we've ever had in
this format I mean you talk about a
class act a great guy I mean he just
doesn't have any of that thing that you
would consider a negative about somebody
who's famous and successful there's no
ego in Chris he's so willing to be a
friend to anyone he meets and and he
belongs in this place that is exactly
what the Opera has always been I mean
there's so many stories over the years
of the camaraderie of this building and
the land what it means to be a part of
this and Chris just epitomizes that in
the way he lives his life in the way he
is towards people now did you see that
Chris picked up Vince Gill when he was
asked are you at all worried about what
he has in store for you tonight if he
tries to pick me up I'm not giving him
the statue and he can suck it I text him
on the way over here actually I was like
thank you so much for being here tonight
man means a lot to me and he goes I sent
him multiple messages trying to get in
to reconsider but they wouldn't so I
guess I'm going to show up which is
exactly what you would expect him to say
yeah that's typical Brad Paisley fashion
yeah yeah Chris told me about the text
message that you sent him earlier very
blase that's me
yeah he was like I can see he was
starting down the path oh just means so
I Love You Man it means so much that
you're gonna do this tonight and I
didn't not want to go there yet so I was
like yeah I tried to I told the operator
making a big mistake
whatever here we honor I don't seem
interested in my opinion so yeah let's
do this
now what will you be performing tonight
me by myself with a guitar so I get to
decide you just get up there and win
yeah I look at these people and see if
they you know try to read what they
might want to hear all right I love
that's one of my favorite things to do
is we play here with the band a lot but
the there's nothing like walking out on
that stage with a guitar you want to be
here when it's someone that matters to
you going in or deep if you have the
opportunity to be a part of an
invitation or an induction or inducing
whatever they call it ingestion yes I
think that's what you want to be here
yeah
how well do you remember your own opera
induction I remember it really well
because I one of the reasons I wanted to
be a member was and that's something
Chris will experience now is no matter
what happens in your career if you ever
feel like singing to an audience full of
people in an incredibly cool place in a
historic place where they love country
music they have to sort that I think
they have to let me do it no matter how
old I get no matter how washed-up I get
they have to let if I call up and say
hey I'm coming next week I think they
kind of gotta say alright now we have to
talk a little bit about the timing of
all of this coming off of you know what
I would presume to be probably one of
the worst nights of your life in Vegas
and then coming here how are you first
of all I'm okay um you know everybody's
gonna cope with that in their own way I
wasn't even supposed to be there a
couple of my friends were playing
obviously Jason Aldean was playing I'm
on tour with him Kane Brown was there
who's gonna be on my tour this year so I
was like man I'm just gonna go down and
hang out with everybody else this will
be you know what you always expect a
concert to be which is a fun night and
obviously the most terrifying night of
my life I had a show two days later in
California that talks a lot too
you know my family my managers my crew
my guys on the road that were already
out there and was like you know I think
I want to play what do you guys want to
do music is something that can heal and
you know everybody's gonna cope in their
own way but that was the right decision
for me
[Music]
so let's talk about the album losing
sleep one of my records that I am so
insanely proud of probably just as proud
of this as anything that I've ever made
I love this album yeah there's so many
really cool things about this you know
it's the first album I've ever done
where I co-wrote everything which was
not intentional
I would never go into a record going
putting that pressure on myself with I'm
gonna write everything where I was
having a conversation with some people
from my label and they're like whoa what
do you have like you know what do you
have done I was like what do you wanna
hear some stuff and played them about
six seven songs and Randy Goodman is the
head of my label was like I love all
those like well I mean we can go cut a
record I guess
[Music]